Shhh!
You love me!
Hahahaha!
Long hair!
Would you love me...
Even if I had no hair?
Look...
I lied.
There is a jump scare.
I forgot to do the face.
The chat disappeared.
Where did it go?
Yay!
Happy Valentine's Day!
I think whoever that was summoned a pretty clingy ghost.
Yay!
Let me put on some music.
I was so nervous everything was going to go okay.
And it seemed mostly okay.
There was a few things I think I messed up, but that's okay!
Music, music, music.
Here we go.
Yay!
And if you guys saw, I gave you a choice.
Did I not?
But you only care about one, huh?
You don't want to see the other, do you?
You don't want to see the other one, do you?
I understand.
We do?
Please?
Okay.
The other one.
Are you ready?
Let me put my arms up too.
Yay!
I finally have my new hair!
I
have some other announcements that you might have seen mid-stream perhaps.
Number one!
Mint's Ghost of a Chance Valentine Collection!
Yay!
We got three things.
There was supposed to be one more thing, but it ended up not working out this time.
But I'm very excited for it, for when it does work out.
So you have the voice pack.
Of a confession.
I felt that the Valentine's Collection was so...
Valentine's-like that...
That...
I needed to make the stream a little spookier than...
Than...
What...
It had to be balanced, you know?
And then they have an indirect kiss mug.
What does that mean?
Do you guys see?
Do you guys see that lip stain?
That's my reel!
I practiced kissing paper 13 times.
So that...
You could...
So that it would look good.
So I tweeted about that, even.
I was just like, I...
I kissed paper.
And now you know the reason why!
Then,
of course, the little Wisp plush pen, which is so cute.
It's so squeezable, you can push, push, push, push.
And plush, plush, plush, plush.
So, yeah!
Store.ghostmade.cafe.
It's a little bit different than my old link.
So, keep that in mind.
And then the second announcement!
That...
That was done on the stream!
Wait, hold on.
Sorry.
This...
Small...
Ta-da!
Oh my gosh.
You guys!
Me and Ayami Mama will be doing a collaboration cafe together in Akihabara!
My favorite, favorite, favorite place ever!
And it will be from March 8th to March 16th.
Which, if you guys are going to a certain other Vtuber event happening that weekend, it might be the perfect time to go!
And I definitely wasn't the one to say, Ayami Mama, you should put it that weekend.
There will maybe be lots of people in Japan who don't usually get to go!
So...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah!
If you have a chance, there will be original merchandise!
And we created our own menu and everything!
So, I'm very, very excited.
And I will be there.
I will be there.
That's why I'm going to Japan.
So I can try the menu and film some stuff that will be playing in the cafe.
And, yeah!
And then, of course, the last announcement was going to be my two hairstyles.
I'm nervous.
Oh my gosh, it's only been... This hasn't even been a half hour!
I didn't eat dinner.
Because I was editing up until...
Pretty close to the stream.
But, yeah!
I hope you guys liked the stream.
Oh, if you didn't realize, if you didn't notice, the website is real!
I basically had to relearn basic HTML to create it.
I tried and I probably put way too much effort.
That's honestly what took the most amount of time.
Was me trying to make the website as accurate feeling as I could to like an old Geocities website.
And I wrote everything on it too, so there's some things that probably you couldn't read during the stream.
Like Cassie's diary.
I had a lot of fun writing those.
And...
Yeah.
Is the ritual real too?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh!
My tab crashed.
The one that I was showing you the window.
I think it crashed because I had... It was repeating too many times maybe.
Thank you for all the superchats you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
So I hope you guys liked the stream.
It was a little...
I didn't want
it to be super overtly spooky, but it's kind of my type of spooky that I like.
Where it's just a little bit more subtle sometimes.
Oh yeah, the poll.
Goodbye poll.
Laptop loop was amazing.
I'm glad you liked it!
The keyboard noises are real.
Yeah, I did everything.
I did everything by myself.
I even had that conversation with myself.
I signed into two different discords on two different browsers.
One was on my phone and one was on the...
One was on the computer.
And so I was... It was a one man show!
I did everything.
Obviously I'm not good enough to do like... What's it called?
Full like website layouts or anything.
So those were all like templates and stuff, but I had to...
I had to move stuff around and I was just like, why is this broken?
Yeah, don't look at the coding, okay?
There's no secrets in the coding!
But there is... I do... I think the site is kind of fun.
I had more stuff I wanted to do for the site too.
Like I wanted to have a guestbook that you could go to, but I just didn't have enough time to implement it.
Because basically I had to make the website as fast as I could, but I was so stuck on being such a perfectionist about certain parts of it...
That I... I... I... I could only film everything today.
Oh!
Did you guys like the hands?
Those are my hands too!
I filmed that.
Basically I didn't have a green screen or anything, so it was super makeshift and everything.
Oh my gosh, it took so much finagling with the chroma key to get it right.
But yeah, I hope you guys liked it.
And then, oh, the page with everybody's stories!
Last night, in a desperate plea to not have to write anything with my own brain anymore...
Because I was like, oh my gosh, this would be the perfect time to use ChatGPT, but I just don't use ChatGPT.
I was coming up with everything myself, and I was like, my brain is fried!
And so I was like, I need customer test... Not customer, but spooky story testimonials.
And so I... I put out a desperate cry for memboos.
If you're not a memboo...
I also... Sorry, my brain is still frazzled.
I also gifted a... What's it called?
A wallpaper.
And I put out a plea in the middle of the night and was like, please, help me!
Just send me some stuff!
Wallpaper.
So...
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
But yeah.
I hope you guys have been having a good Valentine's Day.
I don't have much else I wanted to do because I kind of wanted to keep the stream short so that people could rewatch the...
Well, not rewatch, but watch it pretty easily if they wanted to.
But I saw many, many, many people doing karaoke for Valentine's Day.
And I was like...
I was like, well, I also want to kind of do Valentine's karaoke, but everybody's doing it.
I came up with two songs.
I was like, I'll do one song with my long hair and one song with my twin tails.
But I was like, okay, I know the one song.
And I was going to do one Japanese, one English.
But I was going to do... The song I picked for Japanese song, I was like, wait, this isn't a love song.
I was going to choose Fansa, but it's not really a love song.
So...
I don't know what to sing a love song.
I don't know.
Fansa's sad song?
What?
No, it's not.
It's all about, like, supporting an idol.
It's like the opposite of love song.
It's the opposite of love song.
Oh, really happy I could be a part of this, Mito.
Oh, yes, thank you!
I wonder if the people who submitted their pictures were so shocked to see themselves on the screen.
Mom, that's me!
It's a love song for idol otaku.
So true.
Love the turrets!
Okay, I'll sing then.
I can sing Fansa and I can sing the other song.
I'll sing them and then I'll let you guys get back to all the cooler Valentine's activities that many people are doing, so...
Sound design was top notch.
See, I was listening to it and I didn't have time to listen to...
I noticed some errors, so if you heard any weird... If you heard any errors, sorry.
No, you didn't.
Okay.
Some of the sound design, I was like, oh, I should have balanced that better.
Sorry.
Okay.
Let's sing!
Let's sing, sing, sing, sing, sing, sing, sing.
Also, do you notice Chiyo down here?
I saw... I found that GIF of her when I was...
When I was searching for older 2000 GIFs.
Even though Chiyo is not from 2000, but...
I guess her aesthetic is...
Actually, she's an old VTuber.
Very 2000 looking.
Yeah, very 2000's energy.
Please don't leave Valentine's with yesterday for me!
Wow.
I'm so tired after rushing to complete this.
I hope you guys don't mind that it's a shorter stream.
No delay.
This is the long hair song.
The milky twilight, the
fireflies and silver moon sparkling.
So kiss me.
Or, you could get the indirect kiss mug!
Kissed by yours truly!
Indirectly!
Kiss me.
Down by the broken tree house.
We'll take the trail marked on your father's map.
Kiss me.
Beneath the milky twilight.
So kiss me.
Kiss me.
Beneath the milky
twilight.
Strike up the band and make the silver moon sparkling.
So kiss me.
So
kiss me.
No, it's not.
Oh, I can vote for it.
Vote!
Okay!
Thank you guys!
I hope you like the Valentine's!
I know it's much, much shorter probably than you anticipated, but...
Um...
Yeah!
Yeah, but you know...
Like, I know it's a busy night too, so probably much going on.
You can check out lots of other stuff too!
I'm gonna eat dinner!
Mintos are cute!
Thank you guys for all the superchats!
Thank you for all the beverages!
It was so funny when the chat came up and all you guys started spamming the green...
The member...member messages.
It was funny.
Okay!
Fun stuff!
Oh, I might have to adjust the audio though.
Let me see.
That might be okay.
Okay!
Suki ni natte motto watashi wo mite motto Ongaeshi wa ai no komotta nagekisu de Ki no sei janai me wa atteru yo Heart tsukutte koi shichatte kudasai I'll do anything I can do.
I'll challenge anything without NG.
I found the anti-comment on Egaso.
I know it better than anyone else.
But it's okay.
If I stand here, everyone is here.
Let's go!
Fall in love with me more.
Look at me more.
Give me back my love.
With a love-filled kiss.
Fall in love with me more.
Show me your dream more.
Enjoy it.
A love-filled special night.
Let's have fun!
I can't believe I can spell MOTO with the emoji!
It's so fun!
Please write me a letter.
I'll read it over and over again.
I'll treasure it.
It's still too early for a scandal.
But I won't betray you.
I'll make a declaration.
I won't lose to jealousy and harassment.
I'll win with my mischievous ability.
So I won't stop.
I won't lose.
I'm here.
Let's go!
Raise your fists more.
Sweat more.
Give me back my love.
With a love-filled kiss.
Fall in love with me more.
Show me your dream more.
Enjoy it.
I'll pass it to you.
It's getting closer.
I'm lonely.
It's fun, but I'm about to cry.
I
need you next time.
Let's get stronger.
Enjoy it.
Don't forget more.
I hope it will be a special day.
Let's sing together forever.
Let's walk together forever.
I love you.
Fall in love with me more.
Show me your dream more.
Give me back my love.
With a love-filled kiss.
Show me your dream more.
Enjoy it.
I'll pass it to you.
I have to do it myself.
Bing bing bong...
This is the ending screen.
Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do...
Bing bong, bing bing bing bong...
When will she end the stream?
Who knows?
Bing bing bing bong...
Bing, bing, bing, bing,
bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bing, bing, bing, bong, bong, bing, bong, bing, bing, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong,